I'm gonna fight again for sure you are I
think my plan yeah is to just take this
next year off help out some more
Fighters give someone like the main
event slot there are a lot of people are
very deserving of it you know I will I I
I don't know Ian I feel like my opinion
as a friend you guys put together this
great event maybe just manage it because
like you're just a normal dude and like
I don't know that it's good no but I'm
serious I don't know if it's worth going
out there and taking all these hits to
the head you know you saw how freaked
out Joe Rogan was over the dad fight
last year the pituitary gland uh yes now
dude my pituitary gland is solid he's
had zero brain issues dude he's getting
punched in the head it doesn't matter
you know what I mean like it's not good
for you no you look really good out
there I mean you put you them up
too but that being said Ian you know
that's just that's my thought I don't
know you know I I don't you know that's
sweet I appreciate it as a friend that's
that means a lot to me you're concerned
and I would say the same thing to a b
but I don't think he's fighting again
I'm out